Peck's energy ever get worried about the
volunteers getting injured yes yes I do
like you know sometimes I forget they're
working with huge strong animals I don't
know how you can forget that I think
there's so much you ste like like yes
sometimes I'm scared they will walk up
to him you know there's a body language
something's just not a good idea to get
into that animal sketches well assign it
to you just just listen but you know
they are bringing in in the white I came
in and the white I want to interact and
and you know come and comfort these
animals in just in that this this year
it's possibility for for putting them in
hospital so we try as best we can to to
teach them and explain stuff but you
never know with the world animal you
never know you are where you could be
alone you know what about you how
worried are you about getting injured
you know I know
aftermath but I know in the mornings I
want to come out so these these this
vile rhythms and body language throwing
ears back away they all--they heat you
know those type of things I work a lot
with a body language and just this
sixteenth I don't want them to be in a
situation or put myself in a situation
where anyone will come and kill them for
for their own there's basically nothing
they we grind it away we we all not only
cut the bits off we also then grown away
and and I can I can say to you if that's
a way that we can do it with our God's
God's had died on God's in the not in at
night and then the dogs with the animals
we to try and protect them to try and
stop them being them being poached as
well he sees